martin biron michel suau j michel david
bonsoir autres c'est un peu un piège
pour un politicien que de se faire poser
la question allez-vous mettre de
l'argent public plomb d'un jeu des
contribuables évidemment dans un projet
pour des milliardaires propriétaires de
l'équipe sportive
on a déjà joué dans surnomme monsieur
parizeau avait refusé le contexte était
différent mais d'aider les nordiques à
l'époque
à québec on a fait le stade martin le
pôle arena vidéotron pour une équipe
locale où elle obtient et là le stade de
baseball alors monsieur legault qui
ouvre la porte je vous fais entendre
monsieur legault qui dit oui on pourrait
peut-être une opposition pour vient à
parler en alta si demain matin il y
avait une équipe de baseball au québec
il y aurait des joueurs qui paieraient
des impôts au québec des impôts qu'on
aurait pas si on n'a pas l'équipe de
base-ball donc si on prenne partie de
ses revenus d'impôts là puis qu'on les
donne à une entreprise qui nous amène
cette entreprise là tout le monde est
gagnant
c'est dans ce sens là on a une ouverture
auprès du projet lorsque vous regardez
les priorités budgétaires les ce que
l'on demande au gouvernement où investir
son argent
je pense qu'il ya des priorités qui
doivent passer avant celle là dans une
situation où les finances publiques sont
aussi serré s'il faut mettre de l'argent
aux sports et loisirs au québec
faut le mettre pour encourager les
petits groupes les petites filles
pouvoir pratiquer le sport qui les
passionne mais rien que je souhaiterais
plus que le retour des expos mais je me
vois pas regarder dans les yeux des
familles cherchent une garderie depuis
deux ans en leur disant ben moi j'ai
décidé de prendre cet argent là le petit
plus tôt de le donner
pour vous faire une place en garderie je
vais le mettre dans un stade de baseball
je suis pas capable
le projet dont il est question c'est au
bassin peel
c'est piloté par mr bronfman son
entreprise il ya monsieur bouchard de
couche tard il ya monsieur chrétien de
garda pardon monsieur gabin aussi alors
donc des gens qui ont pas mal d'argent
mais la somme est tellement
considérables martin qu'on a besoin dit
on de l'aide de l'état pour payer le
stade
alors oui c'est ça c'est difficile de
voir quel est le gain politique pour
monsieur legault à ouvrir la tulle au
sortir d'un an de pandémie et à deux
jours du dépôt d'un budget déficitaire
c'est pas un projet qui est neuf c'est
un projet qui date un peu et que
monsieur legault a vu là au début du
mandat au moment où on nageait dans les
surplus et des sondages d'ailleurs qui
avait été publié le tue le dernier le
léger en 2019 disait que les gens
étaient ouverts à l'idée d'avoir un
stade mais qu'ils étaient pas au vert du
tout à l'idée qu' il y avait des fonds
publics qui contribue quand monsieur
legault dit les joueurs vont venir
rester ici ce que je comprends c'est que
c'est ce serait unique et pas garde
partagée on t'aime pas et montréal
peut-être que les joueurs préférés les
paniers de thèmes pas il ne vivrait pas
nécessairement à montréal alors c'est un
pari risqué qui va demander énormément
de pandémie de pédagogie là surtout que
écouter on ne véhiculent aussi le projet
ici à québec là où on n'a jamais vu un
seul joueur de hockey venir s'installer
mais celle ci je bois comme des martyrs
mais les joueurs des deux équipes payent
leurs impôts au québec pour chaque match
qui joue à montréal alors à l'époque
quand monsieur bouchard s'était fait
proposition par d'abord l'abri c'est à
dire une suggestion de notre collègue
martin leclerc qui a l'envié
mettez dans un fonds en fiducie les
impôts des joueurs qui vont bien jouer à
montréal tu n'avais pas être payé ça se
peut que ça marche il faudra refaire les
calculs avec une demi saison sèche
posture mais ce que je suis dont je suis
très simple c'est que les salaires ont
progressé dans le sport professionnel
et c'est 50 multimillionnaire donc
est-ce que vous passez michel que
monsieur legault a des arguments pour
convaincre la population que ce serait
pas une folie la met de l'argent public
dans une aventure comme ça je pense que
le comptable agréé un lui doit avoir des
chiffres devant lui enverrons puis si ce
ne sont pas les eaux tout le monde
espère que l'opération soit
effectivement rentable qu'elle change
d'avis je pense que le pire timing pour
monsieur branson pour arriver avec cette
demande de jeux compacts le projet est
ancien mais la conjoncture une nouvelle
et sylvain sondages je vous dise tout de
suite qu'elle serait la question qui est
parti d'opposition suggérait voulez vous
que le gouvernement met de l'argent dans
un stade ou dans les ch à celle d il est
clair qu actuellement là c'est très très
difficile à défendre comme comme
investissement et je suis convaincu que
d'autres comme michel et qui comme moi
est un amateur de baseball veuille
absolument que qu'on retrouve notre club
mais c'est vrai que les joueurs vont
payer disons la moitié de leurs impôts
au québec mais le stade lui ils vont
être vues de la moitié du temps alors ça
aussi je pense que ça peut devenir un
problème et michel vous qui aimez le
baseball cette idée d' équipe à temps
partagé là est ce que si on fait les
séries on les fait ou on les fait à
temps partagé
je voulais passer franchement mais il se
peut fort bien que ce soit une façon
tout simplement de sortir l'équipe de
pro b qui a un bail pour encore
l'histoire du visage pas trop là et que
ce soit une façon de les faire sortir de
leur jeu je crois que c'est ça parce que
et j'ai je suis pas sûr que tout ce que
je vous dis sur les impôts des joueurs
est il rentable à quatre matchs par
saison il alors mais si j'ai voté chez
lui peut les montrer
mais vous êtes puis martin sheen et à ce
sujet là avec vous ce que michel dit
sexy monsieur legault peut faire la
démonstration que collectivement va
faire de l'argent avec ça là il pourrait
bien avoir un feu entre -1 et rouge mais
plus vert ouais ben il va falloir qu'ils
qu'il démontre clairement parce qu'il ya
quand même d'autres priorités le
présentement comme le disait michel un
titre michel et pts et les
infrastructures sont dans un tel état au
québec on s'envoie déficit est ce que
c'est vraiment ce que les gens en
veulent
la question va se poser puis le
parallèle va se faire aussi avec québec
la construisent et le stade et l'équipe
viendra donc ça soit en même temps mais
savoir également si staline
oui puisque l'équipe de hackers ont
quand même on rappelle dont les gens qui
suivent - soldats encore à québec
la voix il attend là encore d'avantagé
passé puis l'argent a été mis au public
dans le magnifique qu'on pourra le
centre vidéotron qui très bon mais
l'équipe se fait à temps ok sujet triste
si on en parle depuis des semaines et
des semaines je le dis en tout début
d'émission en début de pandémie monsieur
legault avait lors de ses conférences de
presse avaient dire s'il vous plaît
n'hésitez pas dans ce qu'elle a fait de
la délation si vous avez un voisin qui
vous entendez des choses anormales si
vous savez qu'un oncle quelqu'un de
votre famille ils violent envers sa
femme dit le appelé la police n'hésitez
pas mais les craintes étaient justifiées
7e féminicide au québec
cette dame de 29 ans est morte à la
salle aujourd'hui je veux entendre
madame anglade monsieur le groupe ça
rebondit à l'assemblée nationale il est
14h38 présentement mais à 14h27 tantôt
là on vient d'annoncer un septième fils
initial ma question pour le premier
ministre sait quelles sont les actions
que nous allons prendre pour régler et
enrayer cette chute il faut pour faire
ce que vient faire la chef de
l'opposition officielle sur le président
oui le gouvernement a une responsabilité
mais c'est toute la société incluent à
l'opposition officielle qui doit il
travailler ensemble pour en faire un
enjeu partisan
bon c'est pas avec cet échange de qu'on
a beaucoup avancé mais michel david
il ya des publicités qu'on a vu j'en
parlais en début d'émission également
contre la violence faite aux femmes il
ya un financement accru des maisons qui
héberge des femmes mais on a
l'impression que il faudra d'autres
shows dans un plan peut-être encore plus
agressif
je pense que
il va falloir qu'ils rééducation
fondamental ça commence par l'école et
on l'est on peut re pas extirpé ça
l'autre jour au lendemain mais
malheureusement et là la pandémie tout
le monde tout le monde le constate ça a
aggravé la situation
le confinement qui aiguise on exacerbe
les humeurs et même on peut prévoir fait
plusieurs
spécialiste prévoit qu'avec le
déconfinement il ya beaucoup de gens de
conjointe surtout qui retarde le moment
d'annoncer à leurs conjoints qui veulent
se séparer parce que c'est pas évident
de refaire sa vie le comsup en demie
mais au moment où invendus il va y avoir
malheureusement encore des réflexes de
violences et alors qu'il a bel
rééducation dont je parle
ça va prendre du temps alors que le
problème est immédiat et les
gouvernements qu est ce qu ils peuvent
pas changer les mentalités du jour au
lendemain ils vont mettre plus d'argent
dans les organismes qui combattent la
violence conjugale ils vont ils vont
essayer de mieux financer des maisons
d'hébergement mais le problème de fond
monsieur legault là dessus je peux pas
lui donner tort c'est un problème de
société
oui évidemment mais michel c est ce que
la justice
on avait évoqué puis un groupe qui se
penche là-dessus
par exemple des bracelets pour certains
hommes violents pour les tenir à
distance
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une série de
mesures dans la filière justice qu'on
pourrait étudier peut-être plus
rapidement oui certainement mais la
justice simple et qu'à partir du moment
où lieu rue actuelle des fois il ya déjà
il y avait deux lions pas normal il ya
des cas actuellement où il n'y avait pas
de beaucoup de seniors précurseur donc
oui il faut il faut que la justice s'en
occupe il faut que par exemple les gens
qui sont arrêtés pour des très belles
des femmes se doivent par exemple se
présente et l'agent de probation il
passe deux fois les jeux quelque chose
comme ça pendant les procédures etc
on peut faire des choses comme ça mais
ça ne règle pas tout le problème le
problème
une femme surtout si elle a des enfants
est conçu et a plutôt cherché
l'appartement visiter des appartements
et elle est reliée l'a littéralement et
ça c'est un des pires effets secondaires
de cette pandémie
est-ce que vous en souvenez martin quand
monsieur legault et parler de ça en
début de crise a appelé la police qui
n'existait pas on sentait chez les
autorités publiques la pop au jeu sous
chez monsieur lebon une crainte réelle
d'un malheureusement ça s'est produit
est un problème complexe qui est dans
l'est mais en fait d'un ministre que peu
de moyens la ministre qui est
responsable la condition féminine
elle a un tout petit budget et elle est
un peu une quêteuse qui vaut des d'un
ministère à l'autre pour demander
des moyens
et peu plus par exemple parler des
bracelets électroniques
ça relève de la sécurité publique a
lancé c'est à l aller cogner à la porte
à la sécurité publique est temps de
manger à tous les râteliers
quand on parle des maisons par exemple
pour personne pour femmes battues
alors là on est dans les organismes
communautaires le ca relève de la santé
ça peut relever de l'éducation ça peut
relever de la services sociaux
quand on parle des tribunaux pour
spécialiser long et à la justice on
parle d'accompagnement des psychologique
d'être pour les hommes des agresseurs
c'est un problème extrêmement complexe
qui peut qu'y pas globale on n'a pas une
approche unique
ça prendrait en fait une volonté
politique ça dès le premier ministre
devrait dire ou conseil dominé s'écouter
c'est notre priorité
et vous allez donner un peu plus que
quelques millions que vous grappiller
ici et là pour essayer de régler le
problème est là on fonce et on fait
quelque chose et ça ça devient difficile
dans les mains d'isabelle charest qui
plaide me dit-on la situation bon on va
suivre ça budget 19 avril
du côté fédéral et la louis blouin et
nous c'est intéressant ce qui nous a
présenté il est allé faire un tour
élections canada y avait les bois
quelques panneaux on achète des milliers
des milliers de pièces d'équipement pour
construire une nouvelle infrastructure
qu'ovide pour les élections éventuelles
on a posé la question à docteur arruda
voulez-vous être consultés regardez sa
réponse et canon parle d'élection je
pensais être pas dans l'optique du mien
je me rappelle bien au fédéral
ça pourrait non mais écoutez comme je
vous dis on fera l'analyse puis on
appliquera les mêmes principes qu'on
applique dans toutes sortes d'autres
éléments de rassembler vous attendez
doctor who doit être consulté par
élections canada
c'est clair c'est clair que compte tenu
que se fasse nos territoires que ça
concerne notre population
on va demander à ce que ça nous
choisissons mexicaine
chez aux gestes que dr house va être
consulté par élections canada
peut-être qu'on comprendrait une réunion
des directeurs de santé publique de ce
rapport il sera pas consulté par la
première s il veut dès que la chaîne
c'est ça je peux vous dire ça mais c'est
un risque et la maintenir sous trudeau
deux mots là-dessus terre neuve on les
revend les résultats samedi salade
l'élection il ya tellement de choses qui
peuvent mal aller dans une table et
faire une élection fédérale que je pense
que c'est la chose qui va le plus la
retenue dans ses rues et effectivement
il faudrait il faudrait que mais santé
publique dans les provinces soient
consultés ou serait-ce que pour le
déroulement du scrutin
en plus de ça c'est des personnes âgées
les malades qui travaillent dans le lot
scruté comme greffier et cetera là ils
seront peut être pas mal moins
intéressés d'aller d'aller passer la
journée
oui michel séonnet michel avait donc on
voit puis louis nous en à peine levé le
voile mais on aura ce reportage complet
plus tard on voit qu'on se prépare quand
même très sérieusement cette possibilité
là on n'a pas le choix
vous allez me dire élections canada jeu
dating bateau par faut qu'on soit prêt
avez vous l'impression que c'est un
obstacle énorme dans la tête de monsieur
trudeau de dire est ce que si je
déclenche je vais prix avec un ressac
qui va me suivre toute la campe donc je
pense pas que ce soit un gros obstacle
dans l'esprit de monsieur trudeau
doctorat rudel pour prêter très attentif
au cours des dernières semaines pour
avoir encore en tête octobre je pense
que depuis un bon moment on sent que
monsieur trudeau pierre d'impatience et
vous dirais que le congrès conservateur
de la fin de semaine dernière
le certainement pas découragés dans son
envie d'aller en élections non je pense
que monsieur trudeau le scénario dont on
parle depuis plusieurs semaines je pense
va se matérialiser ce à dire que le 19
avril
madame finlande va déposer son budget et
il va servir de base la plateforme
électorale du parti libéral il ya un
risque c'est certain mais c'est un
risque est quand même relativement
calculé je voudrais on ne sait pas
quelle sera la situation en juin mais
c'est tout si tout se déroule comme
comme tout le monde le dit que tout le
monde à peu près et vaccinés à tout cas
une première dose de si la fin juin
c'est donc ça risque d'être moins - marc
été interdit il ya internet
oui plus qu'à terre-neuve martinière on
peut pas s'empêcher de voir le contexte
d'une élection qui s'en vient dans les
annonces
d'abord monsieur le goût c'est le
promesses électorales vous on vous en
parlait hier internet haute vitesse
messieurs legault
monsieur trudeau monsieur legault la
bonne entente ne peut pas s'empêcher d'y
voir un élément électoral quand même là
la machine sous la queue quand on gagne
du temps effectivement pour s'assurer
que les gens soient le plus vaccinée
possible et d'ailleurs au point de
presse de monsieur legault aujourd'hui
ont senti quand même une certaine
confiance en l'avenir on s'attendait
nous allons regarder les chiffres en
disent un peu plus inquiétant mais faut
jamais perdre de vue que l'objectif avec
le vaccin c'est de vacciner en priorité
les plus vulnérables et c2 d'éviter les
décès et les hospitalisations c'est
peut-être que les gens vont attraper la
coved seront malades un peu mais la
pression va baisser sérieusement parce
que rendu à la mi avril le feu en avril
les plus vulnérables devraient pas mal
vaccinés là ça va ouvrir des
possibilités pour monsieur trudeau tour
de table j'ai le temps incertain je vais
en profiter un tour de table sur
justement la vaccination
on a l'impression que ce qui risque de
manquer c'est pas tellement des doses
d'ici quelques semaines
il ya commencent à s'accumuler mais
c'est des brand dans la mesure où il ya
des gens qui sont plus jeunes qui ont
peut-être pas nécessairement à vie
j'entendais ce matin je sais pas si
confirmer ou pas mais j'entendais que
dans certains centres
le soir il restait des doses ce que tous
les gens n'étaient pas s'était pas
présenté mais celle ci rejet est ce
qu'il y aura pas une campagne bien tôt
pour dire allez-y
il va falloir convaincre des gens qui
même dans le réseau de la santé on a vu
les chiffres là avec des gens qui dit
moi je ne veux pas me faire vacciner
c'est sûr qu'il va falloir faire une
campagne - d'emblée mais bon ce fait un
maxi repos besoin d'avoir un groupe une
grosse quarantaine de convives étaient
73 plus long mais ça risque pour les
plus jeunes de se faire faudra voir
quelle est l'évolution de la maladie
ici on est obligé de confiner des drames
la zone rouge certaines régions qui sont
dans son garage actuellement ça va être
une grosse citrouille cette fois michel
david rapidement les tiens je pense
qu'il ya divers façon dont on pourrait
procéder pour amener les plus jeunes à
suivre le mouvement
par exemple les entreprises pourraient
dire bon mais nous on vaccine nos
employés et leurs familles et à partir
de ce moment là il y aurait déjà
disons les trois quarts des enfants au
moins suivrait alors c'est pas
impossible moi ça me paraît pas être un
danger très grande
l'idée que les jeunes voudront pas
failli et a toujours au moins un corps
peut être de la population ne sera pas
vacciner mais honnêtement je pense que
l'objectif est tout à fait atteignable
et monsieur legault rapidement martin
suis vendredi oui vous y avoir des
caméras là c'est son tour il y avait
insisté pour dire qui coupait pas la
file
il vaut mieux y apprit son rendez vous
vendredi on va tous regardés monsieur
legault se faire vacciner
merci à vous trois merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit